what do you do with uh uh reinvesting of
the money would you say we have way too
many soldiers would you cut down on the
amount of soldiers that we have in
america would you cut down on active
duty would you
uh say we don't need as many uh active
duty and navy
army air force whatever uh uh
that we have do we go much lower what do
we do with that money
yeah so
well first of all i think there we
should have a conversation about the
appropriate
size of the us military especially after
withdrawing from afghanistan and
as my hope is as we withdraw
ourselves from and end the other endless
wars
um but
in the short term we can close spaces
abroad and bring troops and family
members remember there were hundreds of
thousands of family members abroad as
well bringing them back to the united
states where they would benefit local
economies bringing troops back from
afghanistan and from germany and
uh from italy from
south korea from japan bringing them
back to florida bringing them back to
california bringing them back to texas
actually benefits those local economies
and there is
excess
infrastructure in the united states to
accommodate them
we take money saved by closing bases
abroad i think first and foremost we
have to look at needs that have been
neglected for far too long again
beginning with pandemic preparedness
with health health care with
ending homelessness in this country
ending hunger in this country improving
our public school system
providing opportunity more opportunities
for people to go to college
at the same time we can be spending
money on the military in far wiser ways
both in terms of where we invest in
infrastructure and in the investments we
make in weaponry i mean we're you know
f-35 this complete boondoggle that's
created a plane that mostly can't fly
can't engage in con in combat
but has cost billions and billions of
dollars that mostly has gone into the
pockets of lockheed martin this is just
a symbol of the problem that is the
military industrial complex or military
industrial congressional complexes as
eisenhower initially called it um it
hasn't been part of the conversation but
part of the reason we are trapped in
this system of permanent war in this
sort of warfare state is because
since world war ii in particular
us leaders have created
and fed a military industrial
congressional complex that has led us
astray that has led us down a path of
permanent war that has benefited the
the weapons manufacturers and and kept
them nice and happy while uh neglecting
human needs that are so
painfully felt by so many people in this
country so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire interview
and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]